hello rejects Greg Alva here got a new
friend on the channel what's her name
hey hope James where you might have seen
on the jab eco a channel my
insignificant brother my puny tiny
out-of-shape brother he's cool he's
alright yeh jabs so I brought a pope
with me a lot of people asked that she
come on the channel she's a fan favorite
of the javi ko a channel so we're gonna
start off here with the 2 a.m. the
smiling man short film this was released
in 2013 it has about 5 million views I
had so many people requested considering
that it's October I figured why not do a
horse or a film for the weekend hook
James are you ready yeah what do you
think of a title so far I love the title
2 a.m. is a scariest time in the world
it is a scary time you never know what's
going down at 2 a.m.
Sammy should be asleep you're awake for
some reason right yeah yeah sure that's
one way to look I've always a week I
just just to find this time yeah
you got a good ass good ass yeah no no
very good
hmmm he's not even looking back he
doesn't actually feel threatened
I like the music
let's keep walking
we fit sir charging at him
why are you standing there
what the hell you want
okay now don't breathe out why are you
not looking at him look up
Oh No
why are you stopping you're not even
looking back I don't believe you
we went home
okay good job on the directing and
editing in there Michael Evans where do
you think this takes place looks like
he'll lie to me probably is I like
knowing short films and all that
based on a true what true story was that
some guy who was creepily smiling cool
cool that was really cool I'm happy I
wasn't bored yeah I think I think that
was a good test in Crete I like creepy
under light like like how it wasn't like
heavily dependent on like editing tricks
it was short it's straight to the point
obviously maybe the only criticisms like
I mean it shot really well to the
Lighting's cool the guy who plays the
smiling man it's really [ __ ] creepy
yeah my only issue sort of is is the
main guy and some choices he was making
like not looking back yeah like not
looking back or like funny just to stop
after a while like a short while of
running yeah I think like he did as he
was directed yeah I don't think it was
like anything this actor chose on his
own was like a bad idea it's a solid
short film it's edited well the music's
really cool - I like that subtle
creepiness of the smiling man as well
because I felt like a lot of people
might have gone all out like weird
makeup or like cheap editing jump cut
tricks and I felt like they just let it
the creepiness just take over of this
guy's performance and the lighting of
the shadows as well yeah I appreciated
that the music didn't overtake it all
yeah true that's what I mean it they
left the actual scene do the job instead
of just them depending on all the things
and posts to really do this and it
wasn't funny it wasn't funny what
very impressive considering he was
[ __ ] weird yeah yeah I've seen people
walk like that before my brother walks
like that whenever he like he sleeps
with a woman he just goes about his day
I mean I was honestly ready to judge at
hardcore but I liked it I know for
watches you were like and you were like
a little worried about you know am I
gonna be am I gonna like this am I gonna
be too harsh on it I think I've just
seen a lot of short films that I don't
like so I already just think I'm yeah I
like them but hey I liked it I hope
isn't an actress so if you want to
audition her you can call her up Michael
she could use the work oh are you I'm
chilling are you sure yeah you sure hope
yeah cool okay I don't need to beg for
things makes me want to look up
Michael's work and see what else he's
done because I would trust him with like
a longer script or like absolutely what
will he do at the future film does he
have a future what's he doing now I feel
like you could adapt us into a feature
film and have Jim Carrey play the
smiling man hmm
you can't Irma I thought it was like a
Jim Carrey look-alike it the background
is mainly Bambi
where did it go what did he do uh his
when he was a boy his mother was a
prostitute and he was forced to have to
watch his mother engage with her clients
well she had to smile and it got the
client so you have this sex yeah great
yes all right well abuse background cool
mother trauma backs of boobs yeah
exactly
why is he stalking someone at 2:00 a.m.
what is it about 2:00 a.m. he killed his
mom at 2:00 a.m. and it was a random
stranger on the street oh no was that
dead like like if the mom would find
clients or random strangers on the
street at 2:00 a.m. when cops aren't
around he really brings go to rich
neighborhoods find people who can afford
her services so he goes looking for
people who are probably and that boy
just looks like that boy just looks like
a creep he's like a pervert yeah he was
a real creepy guy yes
yeah I don't know it's probably it's
just his friend or something they asked
I get spent one thing I would have liked
the scene is like that guy who was
running away from the smiling man look
like he probably could have handled the
guy a little bit at least put up a fight
he was not as scared as me yes a little
more chills I felt like he'd just let
himself get intimidated but he seemed
like a guy who was in shape you lead
seemed kind of muscular yeah it seemed
like he could probably name he's a slow
runner but it seemed like he could fight
him at least and a fella he did like
what was he so scared of I wonder what
it would be like if they replace the guy
with a girl cuz then you afraid this
could be smile a man's gonna like rape
her oh yeah I don't think that's the
angle they wanted you to worry about
which guy I think when like when it
comes to in my territory of rape and
kill I feel like kill is just not as
controversial that weird killing is
ending someone's life we're not gonna
talk about rape on this channel I'm okay
with well guys thanks for recommending
that to us
if you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject hope James is a
dream lady okay a tiger lady I'm cool
the series calm yeah it just takes you
to YouTube right now but we might be on
a different platform soon and you wrote
it
yes directed it um no my friend Abby
directed it she's lovely
um but I covered it with my friend
Kaitlyn and we created a you star in it
yeah hell yeah that's what I do
guys go support her there she's actually
a really funny person
haha she has them in the room laugh and
any time I see her she's just making
everyone laugh honestly times I'm better
that's not true really people laugh at
you or with you or whatever the proper
terminology is I
so usually I just say joke someone laugh
by myself so yeah the law of averages
one to ten make ten jokes one I think
yeah that's when I think everyone thinks
they're their biggest fan but really you
can just like hang out and say hi on
Twitter and I'd be happy with that too
okay